aujourd'hui pour vous parler de terroir
et d'innovation j'avais envie de
raconter l'histoire d'un d'un pays ses
toiles un pays 40 élevé le cros et sur
un pays 40 et le sds plus fun que velcro
c'est l'histoire d'un pays qui a inventé
un avion solaire c'est l'histoire d'un
pays qui fait tous les rings king du
monde en termes d'innovation de
compétitivité et ses terrasses pays
c'est la suisse mais le secret de la
suisse c'est là-dessus j'aimerais
discuter un peu avec vous le secret la
suisse et que tout le monde s'en fout on
a inventé le velcro lsd tout le monde
retient de la suisse au fond ces clichés
dont on parlait avant c'est le chocolat
c'est les montagnes seules c'est le
fromage et jma aussi vous parler d'un
pays qui est parfois tombé dans le piège
qui parfois ne tombent dans le piège de
penser que toutes ces choses qu'on
connaît bien qui font la force du pays
tourisme compagnies ne doivent rien à
l'innovation
au fond c'est des miracles qui tombe du
ciel or non et c'est avec vous
j'aimerais un petit peu vous raconter
cette histoire de ce pays qui a su créer
des innovations et ses innovations sont
devenus les traditions d'aujourd'hui
pour ce faire j'aimerais j'y réfléchis
aux storyteller moi je suis un
storyteller mais si je me suis dit faut
choix et d alors je me suis fait aider
de construite et leurs favoris depuis
quelques quelques semaines c'est à pile
il y appuyer les jeunes aiment beaucoup
à tapis les lignes de ce coin sur sur
twitter happily je l'aimé beaucoup parce
qu'au fond elle représente ça c'est ce
truc là où vous savez il est parfait en
chine ce truc là il est fait dans une
boîte qui fait ça depuis des siècles à
uri ou quelque chose là bas vous
connaissez c'est ces contrées éloignées
et puis c'est elle qui me suit c'est
elle qui me conseille je n'oublie jamais
d'où je viens
mais c'est elle aussi qui met clair un
petit peu sur les forces et les magies
qui font la suisse
donc j'aimerais voyager avec elle tout
d'abord je voyage et au sein d'un cliché
que vous connaissez tous celui du
chocolat aujourd'hui chocolat
reconnaissait bien ici vous en avez une
boîte de chocolat comme vous le savez
probablement il est le fait d'
innovation énorme
le chocolat suisse existe pas parce
qu'on avait dit cacau le saurait mais
avant tout parce qu'un jour
on a inventé la con parce qu'un jour
monsieur nestlé qui se casser un peu la
tête dans ses usines
eh bien il a trouvé le lait en poudre ce
qui nous a permis de faire du lait au
chocolat
c'était à l'époque une énorme explosion
tout comme le café que je présente à
milan personne tout le monde à
l'habitude de prendre du du du café
lyophilisé mais en fait la sphère du
cafi les phillies et c'est un truc assez
dingue et lé brésilien qui en 1930 à une
surproduction de café sait pas quoi
faire
clark a fait perdre de l'argent je
m'appelais suisse le radis faisait pas
une petite solution l' église au
beausset 10 ans et d'en bas ces dix ans
pour pour inventer le café lyophilisé ça
voulait dire que la production était
complètement contrôlé c'est une
révolution énorme ça permis de
populariser le café de faire la richesse
aussi de nestlé mais ça c'est une autre
affaire deuxième voyage que j'aimerais
faire avec vous c'est un voyage au sein
de l'horlogerie l'horlogerie vous me
connaissez probablement tous mais c'est
quand même assez dingue de penser que le
jury est né parce que les paysans c'est
pas ça n'a pas quoi faire le soir c'est
pas quoi faire le soir il était
relativement 12 et au fond les gens qui
ont compris qu'ils avaient un savoir
faire des gens qui ont compris que ces
gestes 7,7 connaissance complète de la
technique déplaisant pouvait servir les
plus gentiment dans le bon vieux jura
ces paysans sont devenus des gens qui
l'hiver travailler sur sur démontré qu'
elle étai travailler sur leurs champs ça
donnait des complications on n'a jamais
réussi à reproduire cette l'innovation
qui continue qui est intéressant dans le
domaine de l'horlogerie peut-être c'est
de devoir aussi qu'on n'est pas
seulement bon temps avec nos petits
paysans qu'ils étaient capables de faire
des mécaniques de précision mais aussi
avec l'invention de la swatch inquiète
eu là par contre une autre force qu'on a
là un pays c'est le savoir anticiper le
management anticipe les tendances
l'invention de la swatch cela continue
de l'innovation dans le domaine de
l'horlogerie prochain voyage que
j'aimerais faire avec vous c'est celui
des transports j'aime bien les
transports parce que ça
ça ira ça nous renvoie à l'histoire et
ça nous renvoie finalement à l'équation
de base ce pays qui était compliqué
l'équation de base avec des montagnes un
peu partout une équation de base avec
peu de matières premières donc une
équation de base qui nous aurait
condamné à être à être pauvres et ceux
n'avais pas réalisé que notre capacité à
avoir des idées notre capacité à
uniformiser à la fois nos transports
uniformiser nos transports avec
notamment nos pays voisins nous allait
nous permettre d'être prospère
aujourd'hui c'est l'histoire de la du
train l'histoire du train notamment en
suisse c'est une innovation permanente
c'est les premiers qu'inventer l'etrat
et qui permettent de monter sur les
montagnes impossible et puis l'année
prochaine comme vous le savez c'est le
plus long tenait tunnel du monde
encore un exemple qui montre que malgré
le côté traditionnel et puis paysagistes
du truc il ya beaucoup d'innovations
derrière prochain voyage que j'aimerais
faire avec vous c'est le voyage qui nous
amène ou insistant et stabler voilà je
voulais vous parler aussi du design et
de l architecture design et architecture
sont intéressants explique peut-être une
des idées explique peut-être pourquoi au
fond on a de la peine à percevoir la
créativité l'innovation de la suisse les
si vous étudiez un petit peu là lors
l'histoire des designers l'histoire des
architectes dans ce pays vous rendez
compte ils ont une obsession c'est la
fonctionnalité
hier j'ai présenté notre pavillon à un
milan et puis j'ai bien senti que les
risques étaient là y'a bon c'est ça
autres pavillons ces détours et urbaines
etc
à côté les français issus du bling-bling
les italiens n'en parle pas
et puis alors on a toutes les peines du
monde pour expliquer que ces de
génie c'est qu'au fond on n'est pas
tellement baroque
ce qui compte pour nous c'est une un
mariage parfait je dirais entre art et
production industrielle c'est ça notre
force et de réfléchir à toute production
artistique dans le cadre d'une
production industrielle
on aime nos architectes c'est plutôt des
ingénieurs au fin de compte le corbusier
ce qu'on peut retenir c'est quand même
le champion du monde du béton il a
évidemment révolutionné l'architecturé
toujours dans cette idée d'ingénierie
sociale
c'est pareil pour nos designers au fond
et c'est un peu difficile pour nous
parce que la plupart du temps personne
sait on a inventé la façon de pelé les
patates la plus rapide possible mais bon
ça c'est ça c'est des choses qui
arrivent mais n'empêche que c'est un
truc qui est dur et continuons le voyage
alors le voyage
je voulais un cliché que le tourisme ça
va dépendre le train a pu faire la photo
des paysages fribourgeois ça c'est un
cliché qui vous parle du touriste bon le
tourisme pour bien reconnaître c'est pas
une invention des suisses est une
invention des anglais sont les anglais
on sera un peu raide on aurait pas de
tourisme par contre si on m'a toujours
intéressé de voir que l'invention des
sports d'hiver est une invention suisse
c'est à dire qu'il ya quand même gars
qui s'est dit bon les anglais viennent
devant l'été à la montagne moi je parie
tout aussi bien en hiver c'est vraiment
sur le tourisme d'hiver suisse c'est une
invention suisse cela dit inspirée par
les anglais c'est pas ça dont je voulais
vous parler ici le tourisme
il m'intéresse aujourd'hui parce que le
fpi de la suisse l' unique selling
propose de la suisse et de donner
l'impression que le paysage a pas bougé
le plaisir est 10ème siècle
et ça c'est quand même extraordinaire
vous aurez chaque fois des gens qui vous
disent je vais ensuite parce que j'ai
l'impression que ça va bouger c'est vrai
ça va bouger et là il faut réfléchir
aussi aux mesures qu'on a prises pour
que ça bouge pas on a quand même une
invention géniale de garder nos paysans
pour qu'ils s'occupent des paysages ça
peut vous faire rigoler mais cela dit je
trouve que dans cette décision est
quelque chose d'important
je ne sais pas ce que vous avez voté en
ce qui concerne les résidences
secondaires je sais pas ce que vous êtes
voter en ce qui concerne la loi sur
l'aménagement du territoire cela dit on
est un des rares pays à avoir des cités
urbaines forte
zurich genève bâle fribourg bientôt et
d'un autre côté à avoir des paysages qui
sont là qui existent et qui n'ont pas
bougé qui permettent de faire une bonne
partie des us fille de ce pays ont
continué le voyage
une des raisons pour lesquelles on est
fort aujourd'hui notre âme et notre
économie c'est cette capacité c'était ce
que françois hollande voulait voir cette
capacité finalement à trouver un
équilibre dans le domaine de la
recherche l'éducation et la science un
équilibre entre le privé le public et ça
c'est essentiel
ce pays s'est constitué sur des bases
libérales ce pays c'est une histoire
intéressante entre l'intervention de
l'état mesurée et une place laissée à
l'économie le meilleur exemple étant
probablement cette formation duale un
tas dire qu'une responsabilité est donné
à l'économie tout en ayant une
intervention d'état qui est forte ou
savez que c'est 80% d'innovation de la
recherche vient de l'économie privée en
france et la moitié moitié
raison pour laquelle nous on continue et
riche et continuera à votre d'impôts et
c'est assez lent ça c'est leur problème
mais jamais oublier que celle que cette
force là c'est probablement des moteurs
moteur qui nous est envié un jeu compte
plus maintenant les demandes de
gouvernements étrangers pour qu'on leur
explique le succès de ce modèle alors on
peut le copier ce modèle mais c'est
quand même 150 ans d'un équilibre
parfois délicat entre l'état et
l'économie privée next
j'aimerais gentiment en conclusion
revenir un peu à ce que j'ai dit au
départ raconte l'histoire d'un pays qui
a su trouver une formule magique mais
l'histoire d'un pays qui parfois aussi
oublier un peu d'où il vient alors vous
avez là le auguste piccard
j'aime bien parce que ça paraisse en a
plein de faire un bathyscaphe qu'on le
voyait comme ça auguste piccard et
bertrand piccard mon a parlé à plusieurs
reprises a pas été reconnu par les siens
1 il a fallu que les américains la navy
s'intéresse parce que fergus picard pour
comprendre que finalement ils avaient
il avait quelque chose à dire il avait
des idées créatives il ya cette tendance
parfois dans ce pays à s'imaginer que la
suisse le modèle suisse là le miracle
suisse et du kof suisse faut un autre
miracle tout ce que je veux donner comme
exemple revient notamment des échanges
avec l'étranger revient d'étrangers qui
sont venus ici qui ont eu des idées des
clés vous le savez c'est un certain
allemand revient de cette capacité à se
mélanger à chercher la créativité chez
l'autre a forcé les échanges et c'est
cet abonné exemple finalement ce picard
là parce qu'il a été reconnu par les
étrangers et ensuite ça a permis quand
même de faire de réaliser l'avion là qui
devrait venir pas le bathyscaphe voilà
donc là ce qui est intéressant dans
cette affaire-là
c'est qu'on voit bien qu'on a un projet
qui a été pensée en suisse mais qui sans
l'apport de deux laboratoires d'argent
et rend étranger aurait jamais eu lieu
ce projet là j'aime bien en parler parce
qu'au fond il est le seul projet qui me
permet un peu de dire que de sortir de
mon discours aujourd'hui parce que ce je
vous ai dit la suisse est vraiment perçu
à travers ses clichés moins perçu au cou
- merci voire pas du tout perçue à
travers sa force d'innovation sauf avec
ce truc là ce truc là elle est le
premier objet qui finalement fait parler
lui de manière extrêmement forte dans
les médias à propos de la force
d'innovation de la suisse est le premier
objet et c'est très intéressant de se
demander pourquoi cet objet là au fond
il est il est aussi fort c'est parce que
pour la première fois on a pensé un
objet et on l'a réalisé jusqu'au bout la
suisse a ce petit défaut de très fort en
sciences pour la montagne la suisse à ce
petit défaut de pain de plus avoir une
grosse industrie est finalement l on
fait souvent des formules chimiques
human brain project pour les autres
entreprises
cette entreprise là au fond elle est de
a à z elle donne véritablement un impact
sur la sur la sur la suisse
j'aimerais finir avec la dernière slide
cette dernière slide qui nous qui nous
rappel n'oubliez jamais d'où vous venez
n'oubliez jamais que finalement la force
qui fait notre pays qui se résume à
travers des clichés vient d'innovation
je le répète ce slogan que j'aime
beaucoup qui achetaient des ravages
c'est à dire que les innovations de
demain aujourd'hui sont les traditions
de demain et puis si dans la khl dans la
salle il ya des entrepreneurs et bien
essayer d'aller jusqu'au bout parce que
tous les produits que vous penserez et
que vous développerez sont pour moi pour
nous pour la suisse des cartes de
visites qui sont relativement importants
parce que moi j'aime bien bouffer du
chocolat mais j'aime bien aussi être
fier d'un gars qui voulait faire le tour
du monde en avion solaire
merci votre attention